BEN SCHROM: Hello, everyone.
Thanks for spending some
time with us this afternoon.
I'm Ben Schrom.
I'm a product manager on
the Google Expeditions team.
And I'm really excited to be
joined here by Jen and Rob,
two of my colleagues.
We're really just
a part, though,
of a small community of really,
really passionate people
here at Google who think
technology can really
change education.
And if it's not obvious already
by virtue of the session,
we're especially
excited about the role
VR can play in education.
So we've just returned,
a little exhausted,
but super-encouraged,
from a year-long trip
that we've taken.
And that trip has been
to try to bring VR
to as many teachers and students
around the world as we could.
And as Clay announced
yesterday, we've
managed to bring expeditions
to over a million students
since last year.
It's a number we're
really, really proud of.
And it's been an
amazing journey.
But so much of the credit
for what follows actually
goes to the amazing group
of teachers and students
who joined us along the way.
We've encountered
so much enthusiasm.
We've received so much
amazing feedback from them.
And we're really, really
grateful to everyone
who has participated and who
continues to participate.
So I'm going to start with
some thoughts about why
VR and education are
a really good match.
And then Jen's going
to talk a little bit
about Google Expeditions
and our Pioneer Program.
And then Rob's going to
talk about the future of VR
in education as we see it.
So let's start with the why.
Like, why did we originally
create Google Expeditions?
And why do we think VR
platforms like Daydream
will offer so much potential
for educators and learners?
Why should developers
like yourselves
be interested in developing
educational apps for VR?
So let's start with a
quick show of hands.
How many of you remember
studying really, really hard
for a test in school?
How many?
Most of you.
How many of you
forgot everything
that you studied the
second after the test?
Exactly the same number, right?
How many of you think you
could do well in that test
again right now?
Not a lot.
[LAUGHTER]
So how many of you
remember a trip
that you've taken to an
interesting place, a country,
a museum, something like that?
About the same number.
How many of you can recall
details about that trip?
A lot of you, right?
So therein lies
one of the reasons
why we find the emergence of
widely accessible VR technology
so exciting for education.
Google I/O is no place to
temper one's enthusiasm.
So I'll make a bold
claim that many of us who
think about educational
technology, VR
is the thing we've
been waiting for,
because it allows us to address
one of the most important,
but neglected areas of learning.
And I want to spend a few
minutes digging into why.
So to start with, let's take a
really, really big step back.
Historically, most
of the technology
that we've developed
to aid learning
has been aimed to enable
access to information--
facts, details, other
observations about the world.
And for most of human
history, a smart person
has basically been someone
who knew a lot of facts.
And fact retention is what a
lot of the technology that we've
built directly supports.
I'm talking about things
like the book, right?
Or libraries of books, a
catalog that lets you easily
access tons and tons
of information quickly.
Search engines, like one
you might recognize here,
have only served to make
this kind of fact retrieval
breathtakingly fast,
comprehensive, and easy.
Even the rapid growth of
technology like laptops,
and tablets, and
smartphones in schools
has only really served to help
you assimilate information
and then turn
around and evaluate
how well you did in absorbing
it and recalling it.
But while information is
super, super important,
it's not even close
to the full story
when it comes to learning.
Let me give you one
example of this.
Here is a math problem.
"There are 26 goats
and 10 sheep on a boat.
How old is the
captain of the boat?"
So a study done in
the US to a bunch
of fifth graders in the
'90s asked this question.
And three-fourths
of those students
produced a numerical
answer to this question.
The most common answer was 36.
There were some 16s.
And amazingly,
there was one 260.
[LAUGHTER]
A quote from one of the students
who answered 36 said, "Well,
for this type of problem,
you need to add, or subtract,
or multiply.
And for this one, it
seemed it was best to add."
[LAUGHTER]
Right?
And the important point, these
kids are not stupid at all.
These are smart kids.
But they're kids for whom
the traditional approaches
to teaching mathematics
are failing.
Let me give you one little
bit more complicated example.
A study done in the '90s found
that when students were taught
geography in a traditional way
by memorizing all the states
and where they go and the
state capitals with a worksheet
like this, they were largely
incapable of naming or placing
those same states in
the correct places
when the borders were
removed like that.
They were basically clueless
the second the map changed.
But the study found that
another group of students
who had spent some time
discussing concepts
like why rivers and
mountain ranges are natural
borders-- they were much more
capable of placing states
in the right spots.
And the reason that's important
is that simple techniques
that literally, in this case,
ground information about which
states are where serve
students to understand
the important concepts
of why-- like,
why are the borders
where they are.
And learning this
way is powerful,
because it allows for much more
improved knowledge transfer.
It allows you to apply the
same thing you learned there
somewhere else.
So you could logically
apply these same lessons
to a map of Europe or whatever.
Let me give you another
very different example.
We've long known that
we have really, really
powerful and innate
spatial memories,
even if we didn't
understand the mechanisms.
This is the reason why most of
you guys can remember the trips
and none of us can
remember the test.
And here's actually a
medieval representation
of the brain that
tried to understand it
as actually a series
of spaces where
you crammed memories and facts,
like an attic or something.
They actually
weren't that far off.
It's the same insight
that has given rise
to that mnemonic device
called a memory palace,
or a mind palace.
For those of you who
don't know what that is,
it basically involves
using our memory
of a place, or better
spatial memory, the rooms
in a familiar building like
your house or your street,
as a structure in which to place
the arbitrary facts that you
remember, say, in this
picture, like a large number
of amphibious species.
So each thing that
you want to remember
gets associated with
the physical space
that you already know.
And then when you
want to recall them,
you visualize that
space you know.
And you use them as a trigger
for that set of arbitrary
facts.
And we've known that this
works for a long time.
Cicero used it to remember
long, long speeches.
But it's a capability
that traditional academics
rarely, rarely tap.
It's one that's easy to
see VR making use of them.
It's only recently
that we've really
begun to understand why
this works that way,
at least scientifically.
The last 30 or so years
have seen a revolution
in the study of
cognition, and especially
in the study of the
science of learning.
For one, we understand
that learning actually
changes the physiology
of the brain.
And we can actually
look for that
when we're studying learning.
We also know-- we have
scientific evidence
that being smart is not
about being informed.
For instance, studies have
shown that very young children
with very little
information quickly
understand fundamental concepts
of numbers, physics, and logic.
And they can learn
these really quickly.
So it turns out that
kids like my 8-month-old
are in fact very smart,
very ignorant little experts
in learning.
And this one remains
a novice in sleeping.
And now that we have all
supercomputers in our pockets,
the notion of smartness
really needs to change, right?
Because being smart
isn't about being
able to repeat and
remember information.
Technology does an amazing
job of doing that for us.
Being smart is being able to
effectively use information
and locate it within concepts.
So as Herbert Simon
says here, the new smart
is being able to sort out what's
deserving of our attention.
And given that most of us have
jobs today that didn't even
exist when we were born,
the ability to learn
is more important than ever.
OK, I'm sure you're all
surprised that I'm not
a cognitive scientist given
my 30 second recap of 30
years of nuanced study.
But the thing that I'm
excited to take away from this
is that it confirms what
great educators have long
known-- that the days
that people learn best,
that the teachers who inspire
their students the best,
that the days when school
is the most effective
are the ones that put
learners in the position
to discover for
themselves, to organize
those facts into concepts,
to turn misconceptions
into metacognition, or
these moments where you're
aware of your own learning
and you can actually
think and reflect on it.
And even if we haven't
had the science
to prove it until
recently, we've
known about this for a
really, really long time.
It almost seems trite
when you read it,
but Aristotle is actually being
sort of profoundly insightful
when he claims that we
learn by doing things.
It's all the more profound
when you go into schools,
and you see how little learning
actually happens by doing.
Even more contemporary
people like one
of the great thinkers
of pedagogy, John Dewey,
was telling us 100
years ago that if we
want to foster learning, we
have to give students something
to do, not something to learn.
And this is when ed tech was
like books on a chalkboard,
right?
One of our most influential
current thinkers
about educational technology,
Seymour Papert-- he
was the guy that created
the first programming
language for kids--
noted that teachers
should concern
themselves with creating
the conditions for learning
rather than providing
information.
And that's one of
the reasons why
he was so passionate about
the freedom of expression kids
get by learning how
to write software.
But even though we've
long had these intuitions,
we've had experts
telling us this,
and now we have science
confirming this,
we don't really have the
technology to scale this stuff.
Think about it.
The technology that
we use is amazing.
My favorite days that
I remember as a student
were in science labs, being
able to look at things up close,
not being able to
predict the outcome.
These are amazing moments.
But this technology is
really hard to scale.
It's expensive.
It breaks.
And it's constrained by time
and safety considerations.
In many, many
countries and places,
these moments just don't happen.
And even more recently,
we've seen this explosion
of really, really
cool robots and stuff
in schools that help you
learn how to code and help you
do logic.
Again, though, these
things are expensive.
They're hard to scale.
And they're relatively limited
in the number of things
that they can do.
Even the classic technology
of this big yellow bus
that takes us on field trips,
again, amazing moments.
It's really expensive.
And it's super-limited
by time and space.
VR gives us new-found
powers to scale and make
experiential, dynamic,
engaging learning a much, much
more regular occurrence.
And the economics
of VR for schools
looks really different
when a single device
can be your science lab-- can
be your programmable robot-- can
give you access to museums,
and can be your school bus.
The very cool thing
that is happening
is that the same technological
revolution that demands we all
get to be better learners is
the same technology that's
going to help us scale
that type of learning.
And to talk about our first
project towards that goal,
I'd like to invite Jen.
[APPLAUSE]
JENNIFER HOLLAND: Thanks,
Ben, for the history lesson.
So I'm program manager
on Google Expeditions.
And at Google I/O last
year, we announced
Expeditions, a new virtual
reality app for schools.
And instead of just
releasing that app,
we actually piloted
with hundreds of schools
all over the world to better
understand how this could
be a powerful learning tool.
And it represents the first
deployment of VR technology
in schools at scale.
And so for those of you that
might not know what Expeditions
is, it combines three things.
One, it's software
built alongside teachers
and students-- two, immersive
virtual reality content--
and three, devices that are
available to any school.
All you need is a smartphone,
a VR viewer, and a tablet.
And you're able to teleport
all over the world.
Actually, you can teleport
all over the Universe
with Expeditions.
And you can laugh and learn
like you're actually there.
And so the
expeditions themselves
are comprised of virtual
reality panoramas.
There are 360-degree
photo spheres
that are annotated with
descriptions and points
of interests, which make it
really easy for the teacher
to actually incorporate
it into their lesson.
And when a teacher points
something out on their tablet,
an arrow pops up on the student
device directing the students
to look in that
particular direction.
And as Ben mentioned, we
were able to bring over
1 million students on an
expedition in 11 countries.
And I want you to think about
that number for a second.
Imagine Shoreline
Amphitheater here
at Google I/O filled
with students.
Every single seat is a student.
Now, multiply that by 150.
And that's how many
students have actually
gone on an expedition
this school year.
And it's still happening today.
If you were to pull out your
phone and look on Twitter
and look at the hashtag
#GoogleExpeditions,
you are going to see so many
kids smiling and excited
about learning.
And I definitely
encourage you to do it.
Just do it after our session.
And we're able to reach that
many students because of how
accessible the hardware is.
You don't need all these
cords and fancy headsets.
You just need devices that
you can pull off the shelf.
So let's take a look at
what one of those classrooms
is experiencing.
And we'll visit the school
that's in Eagle Grove, Iowa.
If we can cue the video.
Actually, don't-- just
kidding-- don't cue that.
Before we visited
schools, we wanted the day
to feel really special.
And we wanted the
kids to be excited
about their virtual
field trip just like they
would a normal field trip.
And so we provided the
students with the gear
that they would need to be
able to go on this expedition.
Just like a normal
physical field trip,
you've got to take notes, and
write down your observations,
and be able to share
them with your peers.
And so the same thing
applied with Expeditions.
And that feedback
has been amazing.
And so now we'll
actually cue the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-My name is Lance Teasley.
I'm in middle school
in Eagle Grove, Iowa.
Eagle Grove is not
a very tall place.
It's actually very flat.
This is the tallest
building on Main Street.
It is about 50-feet tall.
When I grow up, I want to
be an architect and design
skyscrapers.
Yesterday at school, we
went on a class trip.
But this is was not a
normal trip with buses.
This is something
very different.
The very first
expedition we went on
was to the Burj Khalifa.
-Go ahead and grab
with two hands.
And put them up to your face.
-It's so tall.
-OK, we're going to
go to the 153rd floor.
-Yeah!
[CHILDREN EXCLAIMING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
JENNIFER HOLLAND: The
best part of my job
throughout this whole
year has actually
been able to go and visit
these schools-- visit
students like Lance.
So initially, when we
thought about Expeditions,
we thought it would
be about taking kids
to the most majestic
places all over the world.
We thought it was like taking
students to the Taj Mahal.
We thought it might be about
exploring the Great Barrier
Reef or Mt.
Everest, or even Mars.
But what we quickly found
out was that Expeditions
is so much more than that.
It's actually
about enabling kids
to visit places that
might be nearby,
but they might not
be able to get to.
So this picture is
actually a picture
from a middle school, Pryor
Middle School, in Montana.
And many of the students
are of Crow descent.
And every August, there's this
huge powwow and celebration
of the Crow tribe that
happens in Montana.
And many of these students
who live three hours away
from where the celebration is
weren't actually able to go.
So we took our Odyssey
rig-- Google's Jump camera
with GoPro, and we brought it.
And we placed it right in
the middle of that powwow
and right next to the horses
so that all the students
could see the horse parade.
And we took it inside
tepees so that students
could see how a tepee is made.
And we built those expeditions.
And then we took it
to the middle school
so that those students could all
participate in the celebration.
But what was amazing was
that those expeditions
were used around the world
to celebrate that weekend.
And we also know that historical
moments are also really
important teaching moments.
But they sometimes are
difficult to facilitate.
So we've actually found a
way to include rich overlays
and use historical
sound recordings
to evoke a historical setting.
And one of the other
cool things about this
is that we were able to use
some of the same computer vision
techniques that the
Street View team uses
to align this automatically.
And so let's take, for
example, this recent expedition
we created in partnership with
Ken Burns, and Major League
Baseball, and PBS to celebrate
Jackie Robinson's life
and legacy.
This panorama is one
scene from that tour.
And it's of the
March on Washington
and how Jackie Robinson
played a really critical role
in the Civil Rights fight
for African-Americans.
And this 360-degree
panorama was taken recently.
And we found a historical photo
from the March on Washington
and overlaid it
in the exact spot
of where it was taken so that
students could get a better
understanding of that
significance of what took place
over 53 years ago.
And current events are just
as equally important teaching
moments.
But they too are often
difficult to facilitate.
Take two of the most
catastrophic nuclear events
that took place--
Chernobyl and Fukushima.
These are places that you would
never, ever take students to.
But it's actually a really
important teaching moment.
And teachers have had to rely
on videos and news articles
to explain what happened.
But starting today,
schools participating
in the Expeditions Pioneer
Program in our beta
are actually able to go and
visit Chernobyl and Fukushima
and see for themselves
what happened.
And this expedition we
have been creating-- this
is the first current
event expedition
that we've created in
partnership with Getty Images.
And we're also going to be
working with Associated Press
to create more current event
expeditions so that students
all over the world will
be able to visit places
that time, and safety,
and geographic distance
make virtually impossible.
And beyond the
curriculum, we quickly
learn that there's even
broader learning opportunities
with Expeditions.
And it was the vision of
others that helped encourage
us to expand beyond that.
And so the First
Lady saw Expeditions.
And she had a vision for
how she could use it as part
of her Reach Higher Initiative.
For those of you who might not
be familiar about the Reach
Higher Initiative,
the First Lady
has been encouraging
students all over the US
to apply and go to college.
And she saw Expeditions
as a great tool
to use in order to be
able to enable students
to actually visit colleges.
There are a lot of
students out there
who lack the role models who
might have gone to college.
And they themselves might
not be able to imagine what
it's like to go to college.
They might not see
themselves going to college.
And so we wanted
to enable students
all over the world to get
excited about college--
to envision what it's like, to
see how much fun college is,
not only all the people and the
friendships that you'll make,
but also all of the
academic opportunities
that are possible.
And so being able to visualize
what campus life is like
helps encourage students
to take that first step
towards applying for college.
And similarly, when Soledad
O'Brien saw Expeditions,
she had a vision for broadening
kids' exposure to careers.
We know that kids
dream about what they
want to be when they grow up.
But those dreams
are often shaped
by the professional
people in their lives.
And we know that getting
exposure to careers
is an important
learning process.
And this usually happens
through internships.
But what happens if you
don't have an internship,
or you don't have
mentors in your life?
So we've been building a
variety of career expeditions
to show what it's like and what
professional jobs are out there
so that students can
explore the day in
and day out of someone's career.
They can see what
that person studied.
They can find out
what they don't
like about their job,
which is actually a really
important learning opportunity.
And we've worked with a number
of professionals, including
the paleontologist
professor from the American
Museum of Natural History, and
others like Pam Terrell who's
an airline pilot for
American Airlines--
and even an aquarist,
which I didn't even know it
was a career until we built it.
You can laugh.
It's OK.
And it turns out you learn a
lot when you bring your product
to 1 million students.
So I wanted to share
some of those learnings
that we've experienced
along the way.
Number 1, we know that teachers
need very specific tools
to do their job well.
A teacher needs to
be able to direct
their whole class at once.
They need to be able to get
their students' attention.
And they also need to
be able to see what
their students are working on.
And this remains
particularly true in VR.
Teachers aren't experts of
every single place in the world.
So to make it easy to
direct their class,
content providers provide
the descriptions and points
of interests of
particular locations
so that the teacher doesn't
have to spend all the time
researching and fact finding.
So let's take this
panorama for example.
A teacher in the
US may have never
visited Buckingham Palace
before and might not
know that this is
actually the Portrait
Gallery in Buckingham Palace.
And so with these descriptions
and points of interest,
the teacher is able to point
out the famous Canaletto
painting that's hanging
above the fireplace.
We wanted to free
teachers' time up so
they can spend the time
creating engaging lessons
and incorporate it
into their curriculum,
not having to research
all these places.
And when we first
built these tours,
we assigned a grade
and subject to them.
We thought it would make it
easier to find the content.
But what we found was that
the Expeditions were only
used by those teachers in
those grade and subjects, which
limited the use of the app.
And we have over 200
expeditions ranging
from all kinds of topics.
And so we decided to remove
those tags for each expedition,
because what we realized
was that the panoramas don't
actually change.
What changes is how
the teacher actually
applies them to the lesson.
And the minute we did
that, we saw Expeditions
used in the most creative way.
Take, for example, this
expedition of Egypt.
An elementary math teacher
used this expedition
to create a lesson
about how to calculate
the area of a triangle.
Pretty smart.
And that same expedition was
used in a high school world
civilization class to
teach about hieroglyphics
and how ancient Egyptians
communicated with one another.
And that same expedition was
used in a college art history
class to teach about
the art and architecture
of the Egyptian civilization.
Now, if that had been labeled an
elementary math lesson or math
expedition, there is no way that
art history teacher in college
was going to use that lesson.
And so that was one of the
key learnings that we had.
And just like a normal
class, it can sometimes
be difficult to get
a student's attention
during the middle of a lesson.
So imagine that in VR.
Kids are super-excited about
expeditions and VR in general.
And so after a few
pilots, we realized
that we actually needed
to provide a Pause
button for teachers.
So when the teacher
hits that Pause button,
the screen goes black.
And it says,
"Paused by Teacher."
And immediately you hear,
awwww, can we go back?
And instantaneously,
the students
put down their devices.
You don't hear the teacher
say, now put down your devices.
It just happens automatically.
And the Pause
button is easily one
of the most important
features for teachers.
And jokingly, they ask
me if we can add that
to all of their student devices.
And we also heard from teachers
that knowing that students are
engaged is really important.
The way a teacher knows
if a student is engaged
is by looking at what they're
doing-- writing something down,
or looking up at the board.
And that remains really
important in VR as well.
But if you think about it,
when you're in your VR viewer,
the teacher can't see
where you're looking.
And that was
definitely something
that was missing from our
app was the student gaze.
And so we realized that when a
teacher points something out,
they need to be able to see
if the students are actually
looking at it.
So if you look on
the screen, you'll
see these little smiley faces.
And those smiley faces represent
the students in a class.
And so when the teacher
points something out,
you see this swarm
of smiley faces
to that point of interest.
Well, if that swarm
doesn't appear,
and you see students
looking all over the place,
you know that you might need
to use that Pause button
and refocus the class.
The other thing
that we learned was
that VR and Expeditions empowers
students to be teachers.
Teachers don't have
all the answers.
And instead of having all
the answers, what we found
is that the teachers really
serve as a facilitator.
They build upon
what the students
are seeing and exploring
from panorama to panorama.
And across the world,
we saw this thing
happening where teachers
would ask their students
to explore a panorama, find
something interesting, and then
would invite a handful
of the students up
and actually point out that
thing that they thought
was interesting
and talk about it,
and share it with the
rest of their class.
And this is exactly what
Seymour Papert was talking about
in the quote that
Ben referenced,
that the role of the
teacher is to create
the conditions for invention
rather than provide
ready-made knowledge.
And interaction
is really critical
to add to this experience.
And it's something that we
know we need to continue
to add to in Expeditions.
And we also know
that learning happens
outside of the classroom.
Many of us would say that
we're lifelong learners.
And as it turns
out, Expeditions can
be used for a broad range
of learning opportunities
beyond the classroom.
We've actually been piloting
Expeditions in senior citizen
homes and children's hospitals.
And the feedback as well
has been incredible.
We have lots of requests
from senior citizens
to go and visit Verona,
Italy to see the setting
of Romeo and Juliet.
And a lot of kids and
children's hospitals
have been asking
to go underwater.
All they want to do is pick up
the goggles, hold their breath,
go underwater, and explore the
majestic Great Barrier Reef.
And for that moment,
those kids are
forgetting about their illness.
They're smiling.
They're laughing.
And they're asking questions
about what they're seeing
and what they're learning.
So now I'd like to
turn it over to Ben
to talk about group
learning in Expeditions.
[APPLAUSE]
BEN SCHROM: So one of
things that we've seen
is that one of the primary
features of school-- I
didn't love going to
school when I was a kid.
But one of the
things you realize
is that group learning
is actually one
of the best features of school.
An early decision
that we made was
to make Expeditions
fundamentally social.
And many of the
teachers we talked to,
even the ones who had never
seen the cardboard, who
thought Oculus Rift was
like a geological phenomena,
they carried this preconceived
notion that VR was a singular,
isolated activity.
So we took steps from the
get-go to make it social,
something you do with a group
like an actual expedition.
It's not a canned
experience as a result.
Every time is different.
It's a dynamic experience
where your teachers
and your classmates
are the ones who
are asking questions, making
comments, and pointing things
out.
Though I've seen
some great uses of VR
to provide singular focus,
it's really, really important,
I think, for us as a
community of people
who are beginning to build up
this technology, to counteract
this notion that VR
is a fundamentally
isolated experience.
If you're not convinced
of that, there's
a good example
from history, which
was Edison's first attempt at
the camera, the Kinetoscope.
Edison assumed that movies
would turn out to be something
that you just watched alone.
And he resisted projecting
movies onto a screen
so that a bunch of people
could watch at the same time.
We all know how that turned out.
So lots of signals that VR
is super, super important
to have a social element to it.
Another key point, and this
is certainly true, basically
for all technology,
but especially
for educational
technology, is that making
it simple and easy and
especially quick to get going
is really critical.
I remember reading about there's
some warehouse, in Florida
of all places, that
the Air Force can
make super, super cold
like subzero temperatures.
And they put planes in that to
test them before they actually
put them into high altitude.
Classrooms are like that
subzero warehouse, right?
They are very harsh environments
in which to deploy technology.
And it needs to be simple
and robust, or it will fail.
So we found that most
teachers are actually
really skeptical that they could
even use VR in the classroom,
not because they couldn't
figure out how to use,
but because they were
really intimidated by it,
because they thought would
be too complicated to set up,
because they thought it
would be a distraction
for their students.
So we were super-committed
to ensuring that teachers who
hated tech loved Expeditions.
And the best way to do
that was to make it simple.
We found that time
and time again.
It's almost defined by
how few features it has.
It doesn't require
an account login.
And we wanted to
counteract as many
of the technological
prerequisites
as we possibly could.
So we made sure that it worked
well in devices that classrooms
already had like tablets.
You don't need a
Cardboard viewer to do it.
You can do it what
we call magic window
mode where you look in 2D.
And if you've never used VR,
if you've never used Cardboard,
that's actually a really, really
magical amazing experience
by itself.
Another challenge
we encountered was
that getting Expeditions to
work in environments with little
to no internet connectivity
was really challenging.
And that's a very
common scenario
not just in affluent schools,
but in disadvantaged schools.
Many, many schools do not
have the network environment
that would allow them to
pull these super-large VR
assets down out of the
cloud 30 devices at a time.
And we decided we couldn't
wait for Google Fiber.
So we built Expeditions
to work without the need
for the internet.
Basically, the
guide's device-- that
tablet that the
teacher is holding--
operates as a local server.
And it serves imagery to each
of the connected clients, each
of the devices in Cardboard,
over the local Wi-Fi network.
So as long as that tablet
has cached the imagery
from the internet at
some point before,
it works without the
internet, which means
we can take this anywhere.
We can take it to Ghana.
We can take it to
the rural Amazon.
We can take it all
over the place.
This is another one.
Getting beyond this wow moment.
Obviously, we love these
moments when students first
experience Expeditions.
And you saw that in the
video with Lance's class.
Basically, any
chance to see someone
experiencing VR for the first
time is a pretty magical one.
It's an amazing moment.
But the sort of immersion and
engagement that VR provides
is a bit of a moving target.
What we consider
mindblowingly immersive
right now will be
considered table stakes
at some point in the
not too distant future.
And we should be
excited that technology
will continue to push
the boundaries of how
immersive VR can become.
So you should be really
careful to rely too much
on the initial moment of
sort of awe and wonder
that comes from first use.
It won't ultimately
mask poor designs.
And it might
actually distract you
from realizing design
flaws for a long time.
A good piece of VR
learning technology
still needs to be
actually fulfilling
its fundamental
learning objectives.
It's not just about being fun,
or immersive, or engaging.
Measuring it can be really,
really hard at first.
But don't start entirely
trusting your feedback
until your users have been
able to use it for a few hours,
or better yet, a
few days or weeks.
Get feedback, iterate,
ship it, do it a lot,
like basically
fundamental technology,
but super, super
important for VR.
As Jen mentioned, this
is one of the reasons
that we embarked on
the Pioneer Program.
So hopefully we've
seen a little bit
how we think Expeditions can
transform the classroom today.
But we're really, really
excited about the possibility
of more advanced VR
in the classroom.
And to talk a little bit about
that, I'd like to invite Rob.
[APPLAUSE]
ROB JAGNOW: I'm Rob.
I'm going to look into my
crystal ball and in 10 minutes,
try to tell you the
future of VR in education,
which is going to
be really tough.
I built a bunch of
tiny little prototypes
here at Google in a group
called Daydream Labs.
And for the first time ever,
we're finally sharing our work.
So I am really excited to
be here on stage and hope
that everyone can benefit
from sharing and seeing
what we've been working on.
So for now, a little bit more
about Google Expeditions.
Expeditions is amazing.
And I am really proud to be
on the stage with these two.
But we also are very
cognizant that we're
in the early stages of VR.
Hardware will improve,
computational power
will improve, design
patterns will improve,
and some of the
developers in this room
are going to find ways
to use VR in education
that we haven't
even imagined yet.
The slide here is a
pretty common example
of how evolution is portrayed.
You can think of
it as this forward
moving intention direction.
But that's not what evolution
looks like in species.
And it's not what it looks like
in any other technology either.
In any evolutionary
process, we know
that there are going to be
false starts and dead ends.
And that's why within
the Daydream team,
we're spending our time on these
things called Daydream Labs.
Put bluntly, even
here at Google,
we really know that we don't
know very much about VR yet.
So we're looking at highly
experimental ideas that
push the boundary
of VR, force us
to reconsider what's possible.
And we're exploring
this vast new territory
right alongside you.
We've gone back to
first principles.
And we've tried
to set aside what
we think we know about
education and app design,
because the best
VR experiences out
there aren't going to be other
forms of media pulled into VR
and re-imagined in VR.
They're going to be
built from the ground
up in a way that really
understands the strengths
and weaknesses of VR.
And in the near
future, like I said,
I hope we're going to see
entirely new categories of VR
educational experiences.
Now, since we started this
prototyping experiment,
we've built more
than 60 prototypes
that cover of a huge
array of use cases.
So I want to cover
just a few of those.
And this isn't just
to show off our work.
Hopefully, by seeing
some of these examples,
it'll spark ideas
in your own minds.
If you're curious to learn
more about these prototypes,
there are two talks that
took place yesterday.
One is called,
"Daydream Labs-- Lessons
Learned from VR Prototyping."
The second talk is called,
"VR Design Process-- Turning
Fantasy Into Reality."
They're both already
available on YouTube.
But for now, I want to
focus on these prototypes
that we think can really have
the power to change education.
What we're looking at
here is a molecule viewer.
And so much of what we explore
in education is at a scale
that almost completely
defies comprehension.
From atoms and
molecules all the way up
to galaxies and superclusters,
pictures in textbooks
just don't get us excited
about this content.
But what if you could hold
that molecule in your hand?
And the app that
I'm showing here
doesn't just have a couple
of molecules in its database.
It has an enormous collection.
And it builds the model of
the molecule dynamically
based on what it knows about
the chemical composition.
I don't know if you're
familiar with this molecule
in particular.
It's one of the foundations of
life as we know it-- caffeine.
So now let's go 31
orders of magnitude
in the other direction and
take a look at the Milky Way.
Here we see our VR planetarium.
And real planetariums
are amazing.
But here you're in control.
You can pull a
constellation from the night
sky-- pull it right in front
of you to get more information.
Next up, biology lab.
Here what we tell the
student is that you're
an explorer from an
alien civilization
in the distant future.
And you've stumbled
upon this skeleton.
And you're trying to learn
as much as you can about it
by assembling the bones
into a human form.
So a careful observer will see
the different types of joints.
She'll notice that when slender
bones are paired together,
those are the ones that go
the farthest from the body
on the arms and the legs.
Hovering labels tell you that
this is the radius and ulna
or the tibia and fibula.
And all of these
clues give you insight
into the human body in a way
that a textbook really never
could.
Here's our physics lab.
And the key here is that
there are two players
in the same virtual space.
Ben was talking about
how participating
together and having us
be social is important.
And these two players in
the same virtual space
could be in the
same physical room.
Or they could be across
the globe from each other.
Either can change the physics
parameters of the scene
like the mass of
the bowling ball.
And the objective
is to set the values
just right so that the bowling
ball knocks over the pin.
And being able to share
this experience really
amplifies the fun.
Next up is language learning.
And this is such a perfect
example for virtual reality.
It builds on
techniques that we've
been using in
conversational instruction
to put you directly
into the conversation.
And in this video, we've
turned on subtitles
to help you understand
what's going on.
But if you've taken
the time to just learn
a few words in one of
the previous sections
of this educational
app, you have no trouble
participating in this
conversation with these two
young girls.
In this case, VR
does more than just
make you feel like you're
part of the conversation.
It does that very well.
But it also removes distraction
so that you can really
focus on the lesson.
Now, when we're
talking about learning,
sometimes we just
think about kids.
But really, learning
is a lifelong process--
professional skills, job
retraining-- how about a skill
that terrifies most adults,
doing what we're doing up
here-- public speaking.
What if you could prepare
your talk by presenting
to a simulated audience?
We've seen VR used to
help overcome phobias.
And this isn't really
that different.
Public speaking is really
uncomfortable for people who
don't have experience at it.
But in VR, you can simulate
that stressful environment
without fear of judgment
from a real audience.
So that's kind of handy.
Now, let's change pace a
lot and go back to the days
before Google and talk about
the arc of educational games.
So how many people
here died of dysentery?
Not as many as I thought, but
a third of the audience here.
Personally, I see "Oregon
Trail" as actually leading
a revolution in
educational games,
because it was so different.
It wasn't just a
wrapper around a bunch
of boring educational content.
Kids can see right through that.
And I see a lot of educational
games where kids get
spoonfed a bunch of facts,
and then they answer a quiz.
And this almost teaches
them-- it almost
reinforces that learning sucks.
But if you do it,
you get this reward
of the mini game at the end.
This isn't what
we want to teach.
And "Oregon Trail" took a
really different approach.
It didn't try to feed
you this list of facts.
It tried to put you in the
shoes of early American pioneers
so that you can empathize
with the difficulty
of their journey.
And this word empathy
is really important,
because it's something
that VR does really well.
And at the end of
the experience,
maybe you don't remember
how long the Oregon Trail is
or what percentage of
travelers died of dysentery.
But you understand that it
was a brutal experience.
And because of that, the people
who undertook that journey
must have been willing
to shoulder a lot of risk
in search for a better life.
Now, today I think this kind
of experience is really hard.
It has a lot trouble for this
kind of game making inroads
in education, because
it's not easy to measure
what the child learns.
And if you can't
prove that they're
going to do better on
the test, it kind of
looks like a waste of time.
And now you might
really want to come
to the defense of this piece
of childhood nostalgia.
But the critics really
have a point here.
How do you measure the value
of empathy-based education?
And if you think "Oregon
Trail" was on the right track,
I think you'll agree
VR has potential
to really revolutionize this.
But it's not going to be easy.
Let's talk a little bit about
what the ingredients are
that we're going
to need to create
great immersive
educational experiences.
And the three components
that I want to focus on
are these-- immersion,
interactivity,
and measured results.
That third one might
come as a surprise.
Immersion is where
VR really shines.
It's really hard to make
a VR experience that
isn't immersive.
In this example here,
even though the avatars
are very simple and
cartoonish, when
you put that headset
on and those little two
cartoony little girls
turn to face you,
you want to respond to them.
They have included you
in their conversation.
And you don't
hesitate to respond.
Then we have interactivity.
Now, Expeditions, like
most classroom experiences,
is interactive in the
sense that kids can
look around and ask questions.
But ultimately,
the teacher drives
the content and the pace.
And that works very
well in classrooms.
But what if we want
a VR experience
that someone can explore on
their own-- on their own pace,
on their own time.
And in this case, adding
more opportunities
for the viewer to
drive the show can
do a lot to make the
material more engaging.
In this two-player
physics lesson example,
the students have complete
control over the difficulty
level that they choose.
And they're also solving
the puzzle themselves.
And solving that
puzzle on your own
is a lot more rewarding
than watching somebody else
do it or talk you through it.
So here's the tough one.
Finally, it's important that we
measure how students interact
with the VR experience.
It's hugely rewarding to
peek into a classroom that's
doing a Google Expedition,
whether it's kids or adults,
and see all those
giggling faces as they
travel around the world.
But in order for VR to make
real inroads in education,
the subjective evaluation
is not going to be enough.
We need some way to measure how
students interact with the app
and demonstrate the resulting
knowledge of a subject.
And I'm not going to
pretend that this is easy.
People have been trying
this for a long time.
And it's really hard.
Just choosing an
appropriate metric is hard,
and then measuring those
aspects without turning
your application into a
boring quiz is even harder.
I think we're going to
need to rethink both
what we're measuring and
how we're measuring it
for these things
to move forward.
And this is why to some
degree these aspects are
in conflict with each other.
I can make an experience
that's more immersive.
But it's hard to
measure the impact.
I can measure the impact
by forcing students
to answer trivia questions.
But all of a sudden, it's
not immersive anymore.
So it's going to take a
lot of specialized skills
to get this right.
And those specialized
skills are going
to come from specific people.
And I am going to run
through each of these here.
The first one, of
course, is teachers.
Teachers understand
their students.
And they can't be
excluded from this process
in creating these
VR applications.
They need the
flexibility to make sure
that the VR experience is tuned
to the ability and the style
of teaching needed
for their classroom.
Next up, of course,
VR designers--
they know how to make
an immersive experience.
And even within this
group, I'm glossing over
a lot of talent that's needed.
You need to understand 3D
modeling, interaction design,
audio design,
environment layout.
You need to stand understand
what types of motion
makes people sick.
It's really a complicated thing.
Then we have our
classic game designers.
These people know how
to make experiences
that are interactive and
sticky and elicit the desired
behavior.
Next up, and this
is the one that I
think is being excluded
too much in this process,
researchers understand
the metrics of education.
Now, you might
have heard it said
before-- if you can't measure
it, you can't improve it.
In the context of getting
your app out there to schools
and really getting impact
there, the more apt expression
might be, if you can't
measure student improvement,
your app will be discontinued.
And the final element in
the equation is students.
Thankfully, this is
a really easy one.
The students are
the ones who are
the most open to new
ideas in education,
because you don't see a fourth
grader come home from school
and say, mom, I'm not convinced
that this new curriculum
is adequately fulfilling the
pillars of the next generation
science standards.
They say, we went to Europa.
Did you even know that
Europa is a moon of Jupiter.
And it's entirely covered
in a frozen ocean.
How amazing is that?
So I've talked about
the ingredients
for a great educational
VR experience.
And I've talked about
who's going to be
involved in creating them.
But it's still
really hard to give
a roadmap of what the real
process is going to look like.
With technology, ideas, and
patterns moving so quickly,
it's really hard to guess what's
just six months down the road.
So take it with a
grain of salt as I
try to predict how the next
generation of educational VR
experiences will come to be.
I think it's going to start with
existing VR experiences that
aren't necessarily
intended for education.
VR game designers are
going to make something
that's incredibly compelling
and that has a huge audience.
From there, teachers are going
to recognize an opportunity
to use that VR
framework for education.
And "Minecraft"
gives a great example
of a game that's already
been repurposed for education
in all sorts of ways.
From there, we're going
to have to involve
the researchers to figure out
the appropriate metrics that
allow us to measure the impact
of the app on the students'
performance without compromising
the overall experience
of that app.
Working together, the designers,
teachers, and researchers
are going to figure out
a way to put education
at the core of that experience
rather than just making VR
a light layer on top of what is
otherwise an educational app.
What I really want you to take
away from these last few slides
is that a great VR
educational experience will
require multiple disciplines.
We need to engage
new partners and get
outside of our comfort zones.
So I think they're going to play
off the stage pretty soon here.
But I'm going to try
to have us all wrap up
with our own conclusions.
BEN SCHROM: Thanks, Rob.
Yeah, so as I said
at the outset,
we're really excited about VR.
Hopefully, that's
pretty obvious by now.
I think it's actually pretty
rare that we get opportunities
like this as a community of
people that build technology.
It's not rare to find
amazing technology like VR.
And it's not rare to find
causes like education.
But it's rare to find technology
like VR that can so profoundly
scale solutions to an imperative
like education in a way
that long-held
intuition in science
has told us is the right way.
If all of us, or even some
of us, get this right,
it could change the way
that we teach and learn.
And one of the
teachers, this one
that we met on our
Expeditions panel,
told us that the
superpower she most wants
is to be able to make
eye contact with all 30
of her students
at the same time.
What an amazing idea.
And it's probably
too late for us
to have this amazing
teacher in our class.
But it's probably
not too late for us
to give her that superpower
in the near future.
So we're just really, really
excited to see that happen.
JENNIFER HOLLAND:
And virtual reality
will never completely
replace physical field trips
and travel, nor should they.
But it's going to enable
experiences to happen when it
would otherwise be impossible.
And not only will it be a
democratizer of experience
to individuals around the
world and schools and the home.
It's going to be an
enabler of experiences
to distant galaxies, and Mars,
and microscopic worlds that
would otherwise be
virtually impossible.
ROB JAGNOW: And I will
simply conclude by saying,
I want you to be
prepared for surprises.
That amazing VR
experience that is
going to revolutionize
education probably
isn't going to
look like anything
you have ever seen before.
And I hope somebody here
will help us find it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]